somebody once said that the chains of
habit or too light to be felt until
they're too heavy to be broken when you
learn to close you'll never be broke
again you're single you're not good
closer you an entrepreneur you got a
product people are asking three
questions who are you mm-hmm what do you
have and why should I care
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
what's up believe nation at seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the skills
that you need to master for the modern
world also if you want to learn from
Warren Buffett Grant Cardone Les Brown
and other masters check out my 250 for
confidence and 250 for black excellent
series where every day for the next 254
days I will send you a morning video for
free to help you build your confidence
to link to join is in the description
below it's important to associate with
people that are better than yourself you
have to go build self-confidence it's
necessary that you hook up with some
other energy that can take you to the
next level I hope that willingness
unless let's go I said away we go
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be a good public speaker with Warren
Buffett somebody once said that the
chains of heaven are too light to be
felt until they're too heavy to be
broken I have been terrified of public
speaking I couldn't do it and throw up
and I know if I didn't cure it then they
never cured and so I saw an ad in the
paper for the Dale Carnegie horse which
worked on developing your ability to
speak in public and I went down there in
a good mile as the thing that they as a
puppy tell you what a puppy wig they
made it to all these crazy things to get
out of ourselves and so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things
[Applause]
[Music]
if I hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different
so in my office you will not see the
degree I got from the University of
Nebraska will not see big master's
degree I got from Columbia University
but you'll see the little wart
certificate I got from the Dale Carnegie
course
rule number two learn how to close with
dane lock if you're struggling in life
you're struggling in business I can
guarantee you the biggest issue how I've
overcome how I was struggling how
overcome not want to be broke again
it's I learned to close I learned to
communicate ideas thought concepts when
you learn to close you'll never be broke
again because in business nothing
happens until something is sold in life
nothing happens until something is sold
you're single you're not good closer you
can't cause you're not getting our
people to do what you want they're not
following your leadership you can't
close you're not getting sales because
you're lousy closer you can't close when
you can close you can move you can
influence you can persuade people
everything that you want in life guess
what other people already have them I
don't care what is it you want resources
money capital influence relationships
whatever it is that you want you got to
close someone else to give it to you so
if you're struggling financially it
means you're lousy closer it is that
simple what that's the downside of size
this once you know how to close you will
know how to create income on demand you
will know how to make money you have to
build to make money anytime you want
that's the power of closing that's how
you never go broke again
rule number three know how to get
attention with Grant Cardone when I
started Twitter account I had no
followers when I started Facebook
account no followers I was my first
follower when I started Instagram
account no followers
[Music]
I didn't know how to post video I didn't
know how to take a selfie I didn't know
how to do any of this but I did have a
commitment to grow in my finances and if
you want to grow your finances attention
is the gateway you want to go to heaven
who wants to go to heaven you got to die
just telling you man you got to die to
go to the heaven and most people don't
want to die they want to go to heaven
but they don't want that most people
want money but they're not willing to
get the attention they're not willing to
do what it takes to get the attention
including spending money and I would
just tell you this if you want to change
your financial condition the first thing
you need to do is go out and market in
the marketplace so that you can create a
lead and not worry about whether there's
ROI or not it's so stupid that people
like what's the ROI do what's the ROI if
nobody knows you okay what's the ROI if
I don't know your name don't know your
company don't know what you do don't
know your service don't know your
product don't know where you're located
what is the ROI okay best product does
not win today the best known product
wins
you think Starbucks sells the best
coffee please nasty
[Music]
okay but it's closed and I know what I'm
getting when I get there McDonnell sit
let's sell the best Hamburg clothes and
available rule number four be a good
storyteller with Les Brown I think most
businesses fail most brands never make
it most people never reach their
greatness because they don't know how to
tell their story
yes that's major what will you be
sharing with the audience cuz look man
let me says yes while the story is
important is because when you speak if
you're selling yeah you an entrepreneur
you got a product you have an expertise
knowledge is a new currency yeah people
are asking three questions who are you
what do you have and why should I care
mm-hmm and so what if you don't answer
that because we know people do business
who are you yeah what do you have and
why should I care people do business
with people they know like in trust and
when you can answer that now you're
building a rapport and a connection that
creates the possibility where you can do
business together and help each other go
to that next level rule number five
learn how to develop good habits with
James clear one of the phrases I use I
have this in the book is that habits are
the compound interests of
self-improvement so it's like the same
way that it's for a compound interest
you know cruise through finance you're
the effects of your habit to multiply
over time and so often these choices
that you make they're these little 1%
improvements for you or against you each
day and they're very easy to overlook on
a daily basis right like what what
really is the difference between eating
a burger and fries or a salad chicken
for lunch you only thanks a lot that's
actually the moment that's actually a
crucial point that I covered the book
which is that habits that are
immediately satisfying are more likely
to be repeated and so pretty much any
behavior produces multiple outcomes
across time right like if you eat a
doughnut right now it's tasty good but
in the long run you gain weight and so
the the immediate outcome is favorable
the long-term outcome is unfavorable
with good habits just off on the reverse
I'd like you go to the gym right now and
it takes effort you sweat you have to
work hard it's not your time for Netflix
and chill to go train the immediate
outcomes on favor
but the ultimate outcome you're in shape
and you you know a year or month or
whatever is favorable and so the
challenge for building good habits and
breaking bad ones is often finding a way
to pull the long-term consequences of
your bad habits in the immediate moment
so you feel a little to the pain right
now and want to avoid it and the
long-term rewards of your good habits
into the immediate moment so you have a
reason to repeat it again in the future
each behavior Casa vote for the type of
person that you want to become and if
you cast enough votes for that type of
identity you start to believe that about
yourself
right like if you go to church for 20
years you believe that you're religious
you study Spanish every tuesday for 30
minutes you believe that you were
studious so in that way your habits
provide evidence of your desired
identity and I think that that is
probably the ultimate reason that habits
are so importantly it's true like how
this can help you earn more money or be
more productive or lose weight and all
that stuff is great but in addition to
the external results that habits provide
they also shape your sense of self they
like are the at the engine or the Avenue
through which you learn to believe
things about yourself like sometimes
people will say stuff like fake it till
you make it but fake it till you make it
is asking yourself to believe something
without evidence for it and you can do
that for a little while you can do it
for day or week but eventually I mean
there's a word for beliefs that don't
have evidence behind those delusion
right and if you're deluding yourself
then eventually you give up on that but
the power of doing a better habit each
day or casting one little vote for that
type of person is that now you have
evidence to root your belief in okay so
now I've done very last months Yeah
right like yeah I mean now you have a
lot of evidence that you're a podcaster
or a good interviewer you know like you
do this over and over again each time
you cast a vote for believing that about
yourself
and you don't just your delusionally
believing that you're a good interviewer
it's because you've shown up and done it
hundreds of times right and so I think
that that's true for any habit large or
small that they provide evidence of the
desired identity or the the type of
person that you are mm-hmm
what are the five non-negotiable habits
for you on a daily basis oh that's a
good question I think there are a few
core habits that are gonna serve
everybody and certainly serve me well so
exercise is a huge one I don't do it
daily but I exercise Train four times a
week yeah and I feel like if I didn't
exercise I don't know that
would be an entrepreneur like I don't
know if I could handle the psychological
rollercoaster without the physical yeah
the release the you probably feel that
as like an athlete too you know like I
for being an athlete for so many years I
feel like I need to push myself
physically in addition to mentally a
visit just mental it doesn't do it for
me I don't have a physical outlet so
exercise exercise is one the other the
ultimate meta habit is reading because
if you build a habit of reading you can
solve pretty much any other problem you
know you won't learn how to be a better
podcaster you can read about that you
want to run it how to meditate you can
read about that you want to learn how to
make more money you can read about that
and so what you need is to develop a
habit of reading and then whatever
problem you're facing at the time you
can you have a method for solving them
rule number six master PR and marketing
with Robert Kiyosaki when you look at
the big picture there's three things an
entrepreneur must learn number one is PR
and what you're talking about is PR the
other day Fox News interviewed me to
find out if I would endorse my friend
Donald Trump for president you know much
that's worth you know they they call
branded us Kiyosaki read stat and Trump
yeah that's incredibly priceless you
know so getting PR is a number one skill
under that is marketing and marketing
does is like advertising they want to
set the customer up to get ready to buy
oh yeah oh yeah I saw that ki I had I'm
gonna buy a Kia I wanna buy some land
you know I want to buy you this so the
customer is now primed to buy it that's
marking his job then the last thing is a
sale so if you've done a really good job
on PR then you've done a great job on
marketing the sale is like that you know
they walk in they buy but if you have no
PR and you have no marketing you have to
pound pound hard clothes a lot mr.
customer you know you know today's
changing business environment you know
you should buy my insurance you know and
people today hate sales pitches more
than ever before so the number one sales
job of a true entrepreneur is develop
your ability to get PR and I'll say it
again most
entrepreneurs are not good at sales
they're horrible at mark and have no
idea what it is and they can't get any
PR and so they struggle and again sales
equals income to the crash rule number
seven study philosophy with Yuval nor
Harare no questions like free will like
the meaning of humanity philosophers
have been discussing this for thousands
of years with almost zero impact on the
rest of humanity because it was most of
the time irrelevant it didn't really
matter what you think about these issues
but now these problems are suddenly
becoming practical problems of
engineering and of politics so this is
the time for the philosophers and the
historians and the people in the
humanities to go out there and to talk
about these issues it's it is suddenly
very very urgent things that weren't
very urgent in ancient Athens they are
now extremely urgent and what you see is
that the engineers are taking over
because philosophers maybe they are just
too patient well we've been debating
this without 5,000 years we can continue
to debate above 5,000 years more but
engineers are impatient when you design
a self-driving car you can't wait 5,000
years you need to decide ethical
questions and philosophical questions
now or in the next year Oh - sure should
these Silicon Valley companies be hiring
resident philosophers they are doing it
or in different ways either engineers
that reinvent themselves as philosophers
oh there are some philosophers who are
also in at least type of philosophers
who are being hired or play a part in
this and I think again that if you want
to study something really practical in
the 21st century philosophy is a good
vet more than ever before more than many
of the other things that that people are
studying there are so many things that
AI is going to do
than humans in the in the coming years
maybe eventually also philosophy but
this will be one of the last fields to
fall to automation and rule number eight
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is master the art of persuasion
with Edie Milan
persuasion anything so if you want to
persuade your children if you want to
persuade someone to take a look at your
faith if you want to persuade someone in
business if you want to persuade someone
to help you in anything or help them in
anything it's real simple for me
monster belief and so you can't transfer
to me that which you're not experiencing
yourself right so you can't give me a
people always trying to cope with a
magic word
the magic clothes the magic this and
there are words you shouldn't shouldn't
use in persuasion no question about it
right there are think there are words
that are more effective in other words
and clearly to be successful in any
business you need to know what those
words are in your business the best
persuaders the best motivators the best
speakers the best physicians the best
schoolteachers the best parents are
incredible persuaders and what they do
is they come from a monster place of
conviction and belief that they can
transfer you to because people respond
to energy much more than they do words
they respond to what they feel not what
they hear and see hear and see a real
low level influencers energy spirit
transfer of energy is what people
respond to and so I'm cognizant all the
time of getting in a state of total
belief and certainty about what it is
that I'm gonna represent or speaking of
I'm speaking on stage about a particular
topic and then transferring that energy
into people and that seems generic or
hokey but it's actually what great
persuaders do in fact if you're
listening to this you think of anybody
that you know who's incredibly
persuasive they may have great words
they probably do but it's something you
feel from them right and that's the
difference between a great doctor and a
so-so doctor great doctor says here's
the prescription you're out of here
another one is they kind of work or not
well now the other one you leave there
feeling that you're going to be healed
selling you're in good hands you feel
their certainty you feel their
confidence saying when you hear a
speaker if you're buying real estate
from somebody but it's not just buying
things it's a great pastor in a church a
great person if you do TM who's taught
you TM it's there's certainty it's the
energy you feel and
for me it's always getting to I have to
really believe what I'm saying I have to
really feel it to transfer to
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Warren Buffett that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from just watching another
video to actually taking action in your
life or your business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one what's the most important
skill that you need to master from this
list number two who can you learn from
to model success and learn quickly and
number three what are you gonna do today
to take immediate action
people ask me what they
Business School and and and or even if
they don't go to business school what
they need to know before getting in
business and I tell them you know you
have to you have to understand
accounting it's the language of it would
be it's like being in a foreign country
without knowing the language if you're
in business and you don't understand the
accounting so it it you want to get as
comfortable with that as you are with
the English language it it's made me a
lot of money because I I listen to what
Ray Dean had to say fifty three or four
years ago and have been able to
understand what I was seeing on pieces
of paper what that told me about
businesses and the limitations of what
it told me about businesses
if you want to know the 10 skills that
you need to develop to be rich check out
the video right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there without the ability
to influence and persuade your parents
you can't put yourself out there into
the world and you know for what you
really are